we all know the saying all roads lead to
mr wonderful
while this isn't always true kevin is
oftentimes the only shark to make an
offer thank you that's a very generous
offer it is yeah because nobody would
loan you money except mr wonderful
now his offers aren't the cheapest given
that they're riddled with royalties and
debt but he usually asks for less equity
than all the other sharks in many cases
he even offers lower equity deals just
to squeeze the other sharks and force
them to make better offers themselves
the 200 000 as a loan
[Music]
a fail and i'll only and i'll only take
eight percent equity just to mess with
barbara because she said bad things to
me kevin also never puts time limits on
his deals like some other sharks so
though kevin is often portrayed as the
evil bald dude in the middle i think
kevin is actually the fair shark of them
all
in most cases he just wants a fair
evaluation and a clear path to
profitability for himself and the
entrepreneur
despite this kevin is often the last
choice for entrepreneurs which is a
shame given that kevin is usually the
second wealthiest shark in the tank and
the most straightforward so here's the
story of kevin o'leary and how he became
mr wonderful
taking a look back kevin's story dates
back to july 9th 1954 in montreal canada
his official name is actually terence
thomas kevin o'leary so kevin is not
actually his first name
anyway kevin's father was a salesman
while his mother ran a small local
business
this provided the family a decent life
for a couple of years but this didn't
last long
you see kevin's father slowly became
more and more of an alcoholic which
caused several fights between kevin's
parents eventually resulting in a
divorce to make things worse kevin's
father died soon after the divorce when
kevin was just seven years old this
forced kevin's mother georgette to
really grind on the business and look
for other streams of income
most people in this situation would
generally pick up a second job and or
downscale their lives but interestingly
enough georgia decided to make up the
discrepancy through investing every week
georgia invested one third of her
paycheck in large capital
dividend-paying stocks and this is what
really sparked kevin's interest in
business and investing fortunately
things got better financially after
georgette married an economist named
george konowati given that he worked for
the un though the family had to
constantly move around the world usually
this would be a disadvantage because
moving is often just a nuisance but in
kevin's case i think it was actually a
massive advantage because he wasn't
moving from minnesota to michigan or
something he was moving from tunisia to
cyprus to cambodia to ethiopia each of
these places had radically different
cultures languages and traditions which
really opened kevin's eyes to the other
side of the world this actually inspired
kevin to capture his experiences by
becoming a photographer but due to his
stepfather insisting on him attending
college kevin would end up at the
university of waterloo where he majored
in environmental studies and psychology
he would quickly turn around and
complete an mba at the university of
western ontario in 1980 but this was
basically the end of kevin's journey
through the normal path
kevin was pretty set on avoiding a
regular 9-5 ever since his first job at
an ice cream shop kevin was hired as an
ice cream scooper and while this seemed
like a pretty chill high school job to
earn some extra money the money isn't
what drew kevin to the shop the main
reason kevin applied for the job is
because the shop was located in a mall
and this crush elizabeth had a job at
the store right across the ice cream
shop kevin was hoping that by working at
the ice cream shop elizabeth would
notice him and that they could
potentially grab lunch one day but
kevin's dreams were shattered on the
second day
you see right as his second shift came
to an end elizabeth would notice him
this made kevin ecstatic as he could
talk to her right after the job ended
but then the owner of the shop asked
kevin to script the gum off the floor
before leaving for the day given that
elizabeth had noticed him kevin didn't
want to be seen doing such a job so he
came up with a witty response saying
that he was hired to be a scooper not a
scraper and as you would guess this got
kevin fired as soon as kevin got home he
complained to his stepfather about his
experience and told him that he never
wanted to work another job
to this his stepfather replied well even
if you're self-employed you'll be
responsible to customers and
shareholders who are often just as
demanding if not more demanding kevin
says that he refused to believe his
stepfather at the time but now he
realizes that he was completely right
nonetheless kevin was determined to
avoid a traditional job and this is what
drove him towards photography but it
didn't take him long to channel his
energy into a business after college he
would end up starting special event
television or set with two of his mba
classmates they put out some
semi-successful sports programming
including the original six dawn chairs
grapevine and bobby orr and the hockey
league they also produced soccer films
sports documentaries and sports
commercials while this was somewhat
successful kevin knew that this was not
the path that he wanted to go down so
when one of his partners offered to buy
a stick for 25 000
kevin would take the deal he instantly
turned around and used this money to
start a new company and that brings us
the soft key
kevin founded softkey in 1986 with the
two business partners named john freeman
and gary babcock middle class families
were just trying to get their first
computers around this time so kevin knew
that there would be a lot of derived
demand in the coming years looking back
i think kevin would have far prefer to
start a software company like adobe or
autodesk but at the time he ended up
choosing educational software the
reasoning for this was that the
education niche was under targeted by
competitors but this wasn't a mistake
you see the education niche is extremely
difficult because either you're dealing
with schools with extremely restricted
budgets and drama approval processes or
you're dealing with parents who don't
really see the value of their product
the pitch to sell their product isn't
particularly easy either because the
benefit isn't monetary with something
like photoshop the value is obvious you
get photoshop to produce better pictures
and driving more revenue for your
business with educational software
though parents have to hope that the
software helps their kids get a better
education and hope that it makes a
meaningful difference in their lives and
hope that it pays off when they grow up
and start making money as you can see
there are a lot of ifs and hopes and the
roi timeline is extremely long which
makes the business extremely difficult
it didn't take long for kevin to realize
this and this forced him to place a
heavy emphasis on marketing kevin says
quote what's inside the box is important
but it's not as important as how it's
marketed softkey was one of the first
companies to embrace the revolving cd
rack which allowed them to display their
cds more efficiently than any of their
competitors kevin also chose to display
their product in more general stores
like office depot radio shack and smith
books as opposed to just traditional
software stores this showcased the
product to a much broader audience
leading to substantially more revenue
aside from smart marketing kevin also
chose to keep the price of the software
as low as possible at 40 to 100
this left the company with razor thin
profit margins but allowed them to move
much more volume and made it difficult
for new competitors to enter the scene
softkey would become the dominant
education software company by the early
1990s and with that kevin would start to
buy out his competitors
in 1993 softkey would merge with
rollstar international and spinnaker
software to create softkey international
just one year later they would purchase
software marketing corp using 600 000
shares of common stock but their most
influential acquisition didn't come
until 1995 when they got into a bidding
war to purchase the learning company
softkey did end up winning the war but
it would cost them 606 million dollars
around the same time softkey would also
purchase minnesota educational computing
corporation for 370 million dollars
all of this made softkey bigger than
ever before but they were also more
fragile than ever before
all these acquisitions had taken a toll
on softkey's balance sheet and their
razor thin margins didn't help much
either luckily though mattel would offer
to buy the company for 4.2 billion
dollars in 1999. kevin of course took
the deal and this allowed him to sell
his company at the peak of the dotcom
bubble while this was a smart move for
kevin this was disastrous for mattel
in the year following the acquisition
mattel's goal for softkey was a 50
million profit
but the company ended up losing over
double that at 105 million dollars
investors were not happy at all by these
results and they would start to dump
mattel stock leading to a three billion
decrease in mattel's valuation in a
single day
a group of mattel's investors would get
together and file a class action lawsuit
against mattel and kevin for misleading
investors and making a terrible
acquisition kevin and mattel would
initially deny all charges but
eventually mattel would give in
first in 2000 mattel would decide to
dissolve all of softkey's assets they
sold the education division to gore
technology group they sold the
entertainment division to ubisoft and
they sold the brand name of the learning
company to river deep interactive
learning mattel took massive losses on
each of these sales and to make things
worse they agreed to settle the lawsuit
in 2003 by paying out 122 million
dollars this was truly quite unfortunate
for mattel but things couldn't be better
for kevin
kevin says that he was never chasing
money with a soft key but rather chasing
freedom and now that he has sold his
company he had more money than he could
ever need
kevin's net worth is currently estimated
to be around 400 million dollars and
though that's a solid amount it's pretty
modest compared to where he could be
even if kevin just invested all of his
money in something like the s p 500 he'd
likely be worth a few billion dollars
today but kevin has far preferred to
preserve his wealth then grow his wealth
he does have some speculative risky
investments in his portfolio like
bitcoin and tesla but these account for
a very small portion of his portfolio
and he doesn't let them grow past five
percent of his portfolio aside from
limiting his exposure to speculative
investments kevin likes to keep a lot of
his wealth in cash and bonds which is
obviously not the best for growth kevin
also avoids debt like that plague and
advises that people should get rid of
their mortgage as fast as possible
considering this super conservative
investment style it's not clear if kevin
will ever reach the billion dollar mark
but like i said kevin doesn't really
care about that it doesn't really matter
for his kids either as kevin refuses to
leave any inheritance money kevin
believed that you curse a child when you
de-risk their lives and he absolutely
despises entitlement he doesn't want any
of his children or grandchildren to have
a poor childhood due to bad parents
though
so he created a trust that gives his
descendants money up until the day they
graduate college but after that they're
on their own in the meantime kevin has
spent his free time revisiting his
passion for photography apparently he
owns a massive collection of nikon and
canon cameras and he owns every lens he
can think of considering all the work he
put in to get to this point i think it's
only fair that he's finally able to
enjoy his wealth and explore his
passions but that's just what i think
are you guys a fan of mr wonderful
comment that down below also drop a like
if you agree that kevin is the most
underrated shark on shark tank and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm harvey and i'll see you guys on
the next one